d'affaires de rqra pied c'est ça moi je
m'en fous de lui un c'est juste un mec
sans je réfléchis mais tu me ramènes
montrer la saga le monde et dit en plus
anciens étaient clients ouais mais bon
tu peux le faire je pars je me sens pas
un gars va lui faire du mal
encore avec elle fait ça et ça va pas en
quoi c'est cool d'être à bout
je m'appelle quand arrive quand je
t'appelle tron m'a dit pourquoi tu viens
pas pour changer de vue je veux garantir
je vous du rêve
la chambre le bureau la salle de bain
avec la baignoire sabot comme à l'époque
mais du coup on mange dans la baignoire
ça se fait plus en plus on peut pas
habiter avec wagner j'adore tu l'aimés
150 mètres carrés on trouvera jamais
qu'est-ce qui fait la jeune rencontrer
mes nouveaux collègues tu as peur de
craquer c'est sa maman
moi je m'en fous de lui un sélecteur
nexon j'ai réfléchi ça va c'est pas
quand il n'avait jamais vu un poil en
fait et ledit dufau sa meuf je te vois
pas ce que ça prend pour les gens ici et
je suis un peu perdue cup exploitions
par aga le monde et ici en france a été
client ouais mais bon tu fais le phare
sortons bull qui perd demain tu peux
voir tout ce qu'elle fait tu peux
m'abonner mais aussi pour moi je deviens
coin une vieille peau la danseuse étoile
c'est ça qu'on devient 45 manière
générale c'est quoi ça me loue comme moi
révèle que je porte la fin de séance
tandis que celle influenceurs la norme
marc gibert le business à peine au but
c'est cool d'être à bout
page ne sent pas de les faire du mal et
puis ce qui se passe au spa bien ma foi
je sais pas si je fais la bonne bourre
ce tube ma gueule elle n'a jamais à
l'école donc ça y est j'ai un petit peu
de succès que l'on sait ça c'est quoi le
problème on est passé d' important pas
d'accord avec elle c'est ça mais ça va
pas en quoi
[Applaudissements]
si tu regarde un peu autour de toi tu
fais un quart plein de gens qui t'aiment
moi je t'aime et je t'aimerai toujours
je suis là depuis le début
c'est très gênant ce qui vient de se
poser
[Musique]